- [Narrator] In this video,
we're going to talk
about energy conservation
or trying to save or lower the
amount of energy that we use.
Now, a lot of y'all might
already have a sense
that that is a good thing
while others of you might say,
hey why can't I just use
as much energy as possible?
Why should I try to use less energy?
And there's several
answers to that question.
The number one reason is
energy has a huge impact
on the environment.
Most of the energy we produce.
And we'll talk about that in a little bit
has the by-product of
emitting greenhouse gases
which are contributing to global warming.
And then on top of that, it
has implications to society
the infrastructure around us.
And it has frankly impacts on your
and your family's pocketbooks
because energy costs money.
So let's first think about the household.
So this chart right over here,
which is from the U.S. Energy
Information Administration
says residential site electricity
consumption by end use.
And I want to stress that it says
electricity consumption
because electricity consumption
is not the only energy
consumption in a household.
Depending on where you
are it might be around
50 or 60% of consumption
but natural gas is another major source.
And in some cases even petroleum.
But when you look over here,
the major uses of energy in a
household are air conditioning
and that's going to be
especially pronounced
if you live in a hot and
humid part of the country
or part of the world.
You have space heating
which is what most of us
associate with heaters.
And then you have water heating.
Many of y'all probably don't appreciate
when you take those long hot showers
that it took energy to warm up that water.
And then you have lighting.
You have appliances after that.
So as you as an individual
wanted to conserve energy
it makes a lot of sense to
look at things like this.
And so if you wanna
conserve energy at home
use less air conditioning if you can.
Use less heating if you can.
Take shorter showers or
maybe not as hot showers.
And showers not only have
the energy consumption
from heating the water
but it also has the energy
consumption that's happening
at the water treatment
plant to clean your water
and to process your water
that also takes energy.
And right over here is a refrigerator.
And if you have an older refrigerator
or a less efficient refrigerator
that's going to use a lot more
energy to do the same work.
And once again, it's not
just impact on the climate.
It's going to save you
and your family money
by using less energy.
But as we'll see,
energy consumption is
not just a phenomenon
inside of the house.
What we see here is
U.S. energy consumption
by source and sector in 2020.
And this is a little
bit of a complex diagram
but it's telling us a lot of information
Here on the left it tells
us our sources of energy.
So 35% of the energy in the United States
comes from petroleum.
Then 34% from natural gas.
Then 12% from renewable energy.
That'd be things like
wind power or solar power.
Then you have 10% from
coal and 9% from nuclear.
And then not only does this tell us where
the energy is coming from
it's telling us how it is being used.
So we could see 36% in
the industrial sector.
So that's all of the factories
the manufacturing that
produces all of the goods
and services and raw materials
that we have in society.
35% of our energy in the
United States is used
for transportation, moving things around.
Moving ourselves around, but
also moving stuff around.
And then 17% is residential.
12% is commercial.
So this would be things like
the energy that the
shopping mall all is using
or the energy that's being
used in an office building.
This little gray and black
box down here is interesting
because it shows the role of electricity
in this whole scheme.
Sometimes something like petroleum
might be directly used by
say an industrial user,
but sometimes that petroleum is then used
for electricity generation
which can then be used
by these various sectors.
Similarly, something like
coal could be used directly
or it could be used to
produce electricity.
Now one of the eye-popping
things that I didn't appreciate
until I saw this diagram
are the electrical system energy losses,
roughly 65% of the energy is lost.
If you have a more
efficient electrical grid
or we know when to
produce the electricity.
So it more matches up with the demand.
Then we can once again
conserve energy as a society.
And so that's why it's
important to realize
some people think, hey,
if I'm using electricity
or if I'm using an electric car
that maybe has less
impact on the environment.
Well it depends where that
electricity is coming from.
An electric car actually
gives us the option
of not necessarily using petroleum.
It gives us the option of
potentially using renewable energy
or nuclear energy.
But that electricity could be coming from
things that significantly
impact the environment.
But when you generally look at this,
it tells us that as a society
we have to think about things like
investing in public transportation
so that we conserve energy there.
This right over here is a cement plant.
Are there ways to produce these things
that are more efficient
that use less energy.
And then there's regulations that might
motivate us as individuals to
say carpool or drive electric cars
which once again, aren't
necessarily going to be clean.
It depends where that
electricity comes from.
But it gives us the option
of using renewable sources.
So I'll leave you there.
Energy conservation is a complex topic
but a very very very important one.
But hopefully this gives you a start
on how you can look at how
energy is being used in the world
where it comes from and
how you can make a change
both at the personal
level, right over here.
And as a member of our
democracy at the societal level